j'ai pas une voiture
occasion Mercedes
l'assurance le diesel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toujours là toujours le
l'assurance qu'on a 1 ans
ça ça fait bien 200 minutes
[Musique]
très symbolique aussi c'était quelques
jours à Venise quelques jours à venir
qui me dit tu sais quoi je vais t'amener
à Limoges
oui je sortirai cette phrase ça risque
de casser
[Rires]
chante encore une fois ça
si
vous les mettez sur sur sur sur un truc
comme ça mais en fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
SMS
proposer beaucoup
[Rires]
merci
donc c'est pas
attendez je veux bouder ça devient
violent et vous monsieur
[Applaudissements]
on on s'est acheté notre maison Google
permanente et insupportable
[Musique]
non mais non non je peux plus supporter
oui c'est mon frère il demande trop
d'argent j'en ai marre
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui et toi
c'était une grande marque
[Musique]
problème avec votre personne
aller à la Tour Eiffel
[Applaudissements]
les anecdotes sur pigeon. Com
très belle aujourd'hui
alors Isabelle
alors une émission
émission c'est comme un marathon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce
que j'ai offert plein de très beau
cadeau mon mari ou qui perd où il oublie
que c'est moi qui l'ai le faire là
maintenant je vois que des mouches de
pêche qu'il adore
merci
[Applaudissements]
plein de trucs franchement un truc
précis pétuner montre pull mais moi
c'est un peu tous les jours en fait tu
attends pas ton anniversaire
bougie macaron faut éviter
la bougie
l'année dernière à la belle-mère une
bougie avec de la pâte